and we begin this morning with the
investigation of Special Counsel Robert
Muller on election tampering which has
led to the first indictments of Russian
nationals more than a dozen are charged
with conspiracy to tamper with the
election process in an effort to
undermine confidence in US democracy
there is no allegation in the indictment
that anyone in the Trump campaign was
knowingly involved president Trump was
briefed on the matter Friday afternoon
the president ignored shouted questions
from reporters before he left Washington
for a weekend at his Mar Lago Resort
Errol Barnett is with the president in
West Palm Beach
Erol good morning good morning the
Russia investigation was bolstered by
the Deputy Attorney General announcing
in detail charges against Russian
nationals and Russian companies which in
and of itself is unprecedented but with
national security under threat president
Trump chose to comment on his personal
vindication the defendants allegedly
conducted what they called information
warfare against the United States Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein said
Russian nationals using stolen
identities posing as politically active
Americans had a clear and consistent
goal the Russian conspirators want to
promote discord in the United States and
undermine public confidence in democracy
prosecutors say the operation began in
2014 and was run out of this building in
st. Petersburg Russia according to the
37 page indictment 13 Russian nationals
and three Russian companies with a
budget of more than 1.2 million dollars
per month made hundreds of fake social
media profiles posting attacks on
Hillary Clinton while applauding Bernie
Sanders and then Canada Donald Trump
Rosenstein and FBI director Christopher
ray previously briefed President Trump
on this indictment in a statement the
White House said there was no collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia
noting the outcome of the election was
not changed or affected
court documents show Russian operatives
were told to quote use any opportunity
to criticize Hillary Clinton and the
except Sanders and Trump we support them
that was a Democrat hoax it was an
excuse for losing the election president
Trump repeatedly calls the special
counsels probe a hoax tweeting yesterday
the Trump campaign did nothing wrong no
collusion investigators believe the
Russian agenda was also aimed to
suppress minority turnout an Instagram
message from a fake group called woke
blacks discouraged voting for either
party's nominee we could not resort to
the lesser of two Devils it said then
we'd surely be better off without voting
at all but Rosenstein emphasized this
indictment does not claim any American
knowingly played a role in the operation
the nature of the scheme was that the
defendants took extraordinary steps to
make it appear that they were ordinary
American political activists our
Republican House Speaker Paul Ryan says
Washington needs to follow the facts in
the wake of these charges while
Democratic leaders like Senator Chuck
Schumer say this is more proof President
Trump needs to implement the sanctions
against Russia approved by Congress
Anthony
Errol Barnett with the president in
Florida thanks Errol